we have two polar graphs here r is equal
to 3 sine theta and r is equal to 3
cosine theta what we want to do is find
this area shaded in blue that's kind of
the overlap by these two the overlap of
these two circles so encourage you to
pause the video and give it a go
all right so i've assumed i assume
you've you've tried and what's
interesting here is we're clearly
bounded by two different polar graphs
and it looks like they intersect right
over here
if we eyeball it it looks like they're
intersecting at when theta is equal to
pi over four and we can verify that
cosine of pi over four is the same thing
as sine of pi over four
so it is indeed the case that these two
things are going to be equal to each
other they're going to be they're we're
going to be their point of intersection
happens at theta is equal to pi over
four
and if that was wasn't as obvious you
would set these two equal each other and
figure out the thetas where this
actually happened but here it jumps out
at you a little bit more so this is
theta is equal to pi over four
and so the key is to realize is that for
theta
theta being between 0
and pi over 4
we're bounded by the red circle we're
bounded by 3
r is equal to 3 sine theta
and then as we go from pi over 4 to pi
over 2
we are bounded by the black circle we're
bounded by r is equal to 3 cosine theta
so we could just break up our area into
those two regions
so this first area right over here we
already know is going to be half
times the definite integral from 0 to pi
over 4
0 to pi over 4
of what are we bounded by 3 sine of
theta
3 sine of theta and we're going to
square that thing
d theta that's the orange region
and then this i guess you could say this
blue region right over here is going to
be one half times the definite integral
and now we're going to go from pi
over 4 to pi over 2
to pi over 2 of
3 cosine
theta squared
d theta that's this region right over
here
now one thing that might jump out you is
that they're going to be the same area
that these two circles they are i guess
you could say symmetric around this line
theta is equal to pi over four so these
are going to be the same areas so one
thing that we could do is just solve for
one of these and then double it and we
will get this the total region that we
care about so the total area and you can
verify that for yourself if you like but
i'm just going to say that the total
area i'm just going to double this right
over here so the total area if i just
double this just the the orange
expression i'm going to get the definite
integral from 0 to pi over 4
of let's see let me just
of 9 3 squared is 9
sine
squared theta
d
theta
and you could evaluate this by hand you
could evaluate this calculator let's
evaluate this analytically so sine
squared theta is the same thing as one
half times one minus one one half times
one minus cosine of two theta
that's a trigonometric identity that
we've seen a lot in trigonometry in
trigonometry class actually let me just
write it up here so sine
squared theta is equal to one half times
one minus
cosine of two theta
so if we replace this with this
it's going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to let's take
the one-half out so we're going to get 9
halves times the definite integral from
0 to pi over 4
of 1 minus cosine 2 theta
d theta
and so this is going to be equal to 9
halves
9 halves
anti-derivative of 1 is theta and let's
see cosine 2 theta it's going to be
it's going to be negative sine of 2
theta did i do that negative
negative sine
of 2
theta
over
over 2 actually so this is negative
half
sine of two theta and you could do u
substitution and do it like this but
this you might be able to do in your
hand and you can verify the derivative
of sine of two theta is going to be two
cosine of two theta and then you
multiply it times the negative one-half
you multiply times the negative one-half
you just get a negative one right over
there
and
so then we are going to evaluate
this at pi over 4
and at 0. so if you evaluate it at well
luckily if we see if we evaluate this
thing at 0 this whole thing is going to
be 0. so we really just have to evaluate
it at pi over 4. so this is going to be
equal to
9 halves times pi over four
minus
one half
sine
of two times pi over four is pi over two
sine of pi over 2 sine of pi over 2 we
already know is 1.
so it is really pi over 4 so this this
right over here is just going to be
equal to 1.
so this is going to be
9 halves
times we could say pi over 4 minus one
half or we could say pi
over 4
minus 2 over 4. so we could write it
like that or we could multiply
everything out or we could say this is
going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 9
pi
minus
9 pi minus 18
over
over 8.
and
we
are done